[Music]
on this Sunday night holiday headaches
and heartaches Christmas Day upended for
some unlucky Travelers they really just
left
the grounded flights frustration and
fatigue
celebrating Christmas during Russia's
War they want to destroy all our
holidays the Defiance of ukrainians and
the suspicions of what Putin is up to
now
Merry Christmas when the giving season
collides with tough times that's deeply
troubling how inflation is deflating
generosity
and new year new strategies the
potential changes Britain's PM could
make
[Music]
global national with Paul Nasser
reporting tonight Colleen Christie good
evening and Merry Christmas on a day
when many Canadians are spending time
with loved ones and having fun some
aren't so fortunate bad weather has
cruelly thrown a wrench into their plans
thousands woke up without electricity
this morning after ferocious conditions
caused power outages across Ontario
Quebec and New Brunswick others are
camped out at airports feeling powerless
nitugartia tonight on how this festive
season has turned to frustration
sleeping at the airport in Toronto this
Hungarian hockey team didn't expect this
would be how they'd spend Christmas
morning we are talking about
1670 year old players so they just got
the news that actually the the
rescheduled flight is also canceled 22
players and six coaching staff tried to
get to Calgary for one of the city's
biggest u18 AAA tournaments ever
starting on Tuesday I think Canada is
really really famous about isuki and
Hospitality so we are really believing
in Christmas miracles like thousands of
others across the country their plans
thrown into limbo they really just left
this here
for Carol joy and Scott Greene who are
trying to get home to Prince George BC
after visiting their kids in Ontario the
experience has been exhausting and
emotional we're waiting to see if any of
our friends have have a place we could
crash at otherwise by the time we pay
for hotels and meals we could just about
pay for two new tickets back to our home
the couple now stuck at Vancouver
International Airport says they waited
on the tarmac in Toronto for nearly five
hours there's been virtually no
communication with us we've had to
initiate everything I have to say that I
think we we feel really abandoned
meanwhile in Surrey BC Jazz Gill is
spending her first Christmas away from
her relatives the Seattle Resident was
prepared to host her family from
California but then their flight was
canceled due to weather to prevent her
from spending Christmas alone her
Canadian boyfriend picked her up you
have to cancel all those plans that we
had as well even my younger siblings I
haven't seen them in a really long time
so I had presents for them too that now
I have to ship to them
um but yeah so it was really
heartbreaking and I do miss them a lot
so a makeshift airport soccer match an
example of how many people are trying to
make the most of their Christmas as
weather and travel delays wreak havoc on
their holiday plans
Global News Surrey BC
a boss has crushed in BC's interior
killing four people and injuring dozens
of others it happened last night on
Highway 97c between Merit and Kelowna
while it was snowing investigators
suspect extremely icy conditions caused
the bus to roll over into oncoming
traffic and that it did not collide with
any other vehicles the bus operator
confirms 47 people were on board at the
time
on this Christmas day in Ukraine's
Capital people gathered inside a train
station to sing Christmas carols
foreign
the festive spirit filled the Kiev Metro
even as air raid sirens wailed across
the country Russian President Vladimir
Putin is now publicly changing his
stance on his invasion of Ukraine but as
Mackenzie gray explains Ukraine and the
West aren't buying it
[Music]
the sounds of hymns across Ukraine
signals a new tradition
for Generations Christians in Ukraine
and Russia celebrated Christmas on
January 7th but in the latest rejection
of Moscow the Ukrainian Orthodox Church
is celebrating today
this is a significant event for the
whole of Ukraine citizens we've been
fighting for a long time to celebrate
Christmas on December 25th
but there was no Christmas reprieve from
the war the death toll has now reached
16 in Kirsten after a Russian strike a
civilian was here said the soldier the
car burned down despite the attacks
Russian President Vladimir Putin media
he's willing to have talks to end the
war we are ready to negotiate with
everyone involved about acceptable
Solutions but that is up to them we are
not the ones refusing to negotiate they
are
Ukrainian Western allies suspect Putin's
claims are a ploy to buy time after
multiple Russian military defeats Putin
needs to come back to reality tweeted a
key advisor to Ukrainian President
Vladimir zielinski Russia
single-handedly attacked Ukraine and is
killing citizens
himself uses Christmas address to warn
ukrainians of the hardships
our fight will continue unabated it is
not threatened by planned or emergency
blackouts he said
[Music]
those power outages the result of
Russian strikes on Ukrainian key
interests
leaving families like Leslie azadilskias
to eat dinner by candlelight and cook
over our gas camping we know they want
to destroy all our holidays so some
holidays for us they could be targets
for them just like it is in her Zone the
Christmas spirit still shining
throughout Ukraine Mackenzie gray Global
News
Ottawa as inflation eats away at many
Canadians incomes charitable donations
are paying the price Ross Lord looks at
the shortfall one major organization is
reporting and its message to people who
have nothing to spare
in this holiday season the Salvation
Army says there's an alarming increase
in need across Canada but in the days
leading up to Christmas the Charities
Kettle campaign was four million dollars
short of its 22 million dollar National
Target thank you so so much okay you're
welcome we're to date receiving uh less
donations you have to request for
assistance have uh have really
skyrocketed and so that's uh deeply
troubling for us as an organization not
surprising when you consider many
Canadians have been struggling under the
weight of record high inflation all year
giving to charity is a tough ask for
people feeling pressure just to give
gifts to their loved ones uh probably
spending less money to be honest we'll
just cut back a bit and give some gift
cards a survey conducted by the charity
sector indicates a drop in the number of
Canadians who intend to donate just
under half are saying they intend to
give this holiday season which is down
about eight points from last year and
amongst those who are planning to donate
over the holidays almost 40 percent are
saying they're going to give less which
I think is a reflection of these
Economic Times with less to give and
More in need it's a double blow for
groups and services that just want to
help those statistics represent
individuals they rep present families
they represent friends and families and
co-workers and people who historically
and traditionally have not had to come
to the Salvation Army for help
Lieutenant Colonel Murray says the
Salvation Army doesn't want Canadians
who are struggling to feel even worse
for not giving to charity he hopes those
who can Will
Ross Lord Global News
it's the Canadian Health Care crisis for
those who can't speak up for themselves
coming up the veterinarian shortage and
what's being suggested as a solution
foreign
[Music]
hospitals to ambulance shortages by now
you know about the cracks in Canada's
Health Care System but there's another
sector struggling that's getting less
attention veterinary medicine more
people are getting pets but right across
Canada they're having a tough time
finding vets and vet techs Global Sarah
Reed looks at how Alberta's aiming to
solve the problem and what one vet
believes the industry needs to do
for 35 years Dr Ross fulston has been
caring for people's pets I love my
career and I am very proud to be a
veterinarian but a shortage of vets and
vet techs is making it more challenging
positions are going unfilled meaning
more work for those dealing with an
already demanding industry my colleague
just got back from her second maternity
leave the fill in the blanks for me is I
worked every single day six days a week
in this practice without anything more
than a Sunday off the Alberta Veterinary
Medical Association says there are more
than 850 vacant vet positions across the
province a number that's more than
doubled since 2019 and it's not just
vets but also vet techs in 2021 vacancy
rates for that position hit almost 20
percent we hadn't really increased the
number of veterinarians we were training
in western Canada for quite some time
when the covid-19 pandemic hit there was
a a big change because there was an
expansion in the number of pets vets say
those changes in the industry now make
caring for their patients more
challenging there's times that a client
will call with a pet health need
that my schedules fall and I can't
accommodate helping them in an effort to
address the shortage the province has
committed 59 million dollars to expand
the veterinary medicine program at the
UFC but it doesn't provide an immediate
solution you can buy a dog in a day you
can't make a veterinarian it takes eight
years right it also doesn't directly
address the shortage in rural
communities that's why Dr folston is
suggesting the industry reevaluates
selection criteria to make veterinary
medicine more accessible to students who
could fill rules in rural communities
increasing maybe the enrollment and the
successful
um
selection of rural people that probably
have a better chance of going back into
food or mixed animal practice in rural
settings he hopes increasing the number
of people entering his profession
eventually means more weekends to
recover it was tremendous I'd forgotten
what it was like to have a Saturday and
a Sunday off it was kind of a novel
thing Sarah Reed Global News
I had what's being called the most
remarkable year ever in British politics
and what's next
[Music]
2022 was nothing short of remarkable and
historic for Britain the death of Queen
Elizabeth II along with an unforgettable
mind-boggling period in politics with
three prime ministers at the helm one
being Lee's trust who lasted only six
weeks Redmond Shannon looks at how it
all played out and what could be next
for the UK
Britain's economy is treading water and
the Outlook appears to be Bleak for the
coming year a storm that brewed in 2022
as the country so tumultuous so people
two changes of prime minister and the
change of Monarch as seven decades of
the Elizabethan era came to a close I
think this year's been the most
remarkable year ever in British Politics
the longevity of that monarchy compared
to the short-termism of British Politics
the contrast could hardly be greater
will you take responsibility Minister
earlier in the year Boris Johnson
appeared to be close to riding out the
scandals of partygate the Downing Street
Gatherings that broke covid-19 lockdown
rules
at the Queen's Platinum Jubilee in June
the jeers showed he was on thin ice the
game was up when it emerged Johnson knew
about but ignored sexual harassment
claims against his deputy chief whip in
the leadership campaign to replace him
former Finance Minister Rishi sunak
warned fellow candidate Liz truss her
tax cut plan for the rich would not work
for a pensioner who's not working that
tax cut is worth precisely zero despite
sunak being the Preferred Choice among
MPS truss won the contest thanks to the
votes of regular party members however
once in office her tax cut plans caused
chaos in the markets drawing criticism
from the IMF and the bank of England by
the time Tross eventually you turned on
the tax cuts her Authority had collapsed
I really shouldn't say this but I hope
all those people that put this trust in
number 10 I hope it was worth it
the new PM became quite literally an
object of ridicule a tabloid set up a
live stream of a lettuce to see if it
would Outlast the beleaguered but
defiant leader I am a fight
ER she did quit the letters had won
trust becoming the shortest Serving
Leader in British history sunak was the
clear front-runner to replace her
amazingly Boris Johnson explored what
would have been a remarkable comeback
but eventually decided not to run
because he knows that whoever's in
charge can't really change the economic
realities that are confronting Britain a
recession lack of economic progress High
inflation so it was sunak who inherited
that long list of headaches it's
predicted Britain will have the slowest
growth of any G7 nation in 2023 that
perhaps contributing to the apparent
buyer's remorse over brexit an event
arguably the root cause of much of this
turmoil two years since the UK fully
left the EU pulls indicate as few as a
third of britons think it was a good
idea a new battle is brewing with
Edinburgh too over consent for another
Scottish independence referendum on
foreign policy sunac has hinted at some
change we also need to evolve our
approach to China
now let's be clear the so-called Golden
Era is over in reality the UK's Global
relations are unlikely to differ much
from his predecessors or Western allies
like Canada strong support for Ukraine
will continue in fact sunac may have
brought back a sense of stability to
Westminster after the scandals of
Johnson and the chaos of truss but it
looks like bringing back the governing
Tories to power in 2024 will be his
toughest task of all as he faces a
series of industrial strikes and a
stagnant post-brexit economy Britain
waiting in the wings opposition leader
Kier starmer proposing to abolish the
Antiquated House of Lords in favor of an
elected upper chamber and he says he
wants to transfer more powers to the UK
Nations and regions starmer is also
often accused of being dull perhaps
that's exactly what British voters will
be looking for Redmond Shannon Global
News London
next
holiday traditions snapshots of our
colleagues and who keeps us company
[Music]
it's time to honor all of the people who
work tirelessly to bring you global
national the West block and the new
reality our teams are small but bringing
you these broadcasts is no small feat
you're about to meet them they're pets
because they're family too and some of
the newest members of the global news
family I'm Colleen Christie on behalf of
everyone here at global news thanks for
your trust and support over the past
Year wishing you and your loved ones a
safe and happy Christmas and holiday
season good night
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
School Board in the
Kindersley area has declared that
students will go
into a whole dance again yeah I'm fine
yeah we've got some wind here a National
Emergency has been
has been invoked but the weather in
Pakistan extreme weather is alarming
with the garcha reports
[Music]
oh my god oh there's a bee
oh my God I'm tired there's a bee and I
can't go anywhere this is like my big
fear in life I love you we need you for
the planet's sake but I'm scared of you
oh I think it's done
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]